this is my fixed time you already had my
childhood you flew planes you had
adventures and you fell in love i am the
nerd with an inhaler who gets his ass
kicked after class and that's the only
thing i've gotten to be so far i want
the rest of it this is my fixed time you
already had my childhood that adventure
she flew planes and i'm still the nerve
with an inhaler who gets his ass kicked
i want the rest of it we could change
all of that by destroying time travel
right
how are you gonna do that exactly you
know what what's your plan we can fix it
by destroying time travel that's right
and how are you gonna do that what's
your plan he played catch with us almost
every night i be in the yard throwing
the ball against the pitch back you
remember the pitch back right he bought
it because they have one in the window
of almonds play catch with us
almost every night i've been here i
throw the ball against the pitch back
you remember the pitch back right right
he bought it because they had one of the
window of almonds